les commerces concernés par les
exceptions des règles du confinement les
bureaux de tabac sont touchés nos
équipes ont suivi franklin de ces
buralistes qui n'ont pas fermé boutique
on voit ça avec grégoire doucet et
louise carvalho chaque jour depuis que
les mesures de confinement ont été mises
en place franck kalt année-là continue
d'ouvrir son bureau de tabac situé à
deux pas de la place des terreaux à lyon
on entame la deuxième semaine et les
gestes barrières sont bien là assurer sa
propre protection mais aussi celle de
ses clients le commerçant enfile des
gants et son masque ne le quitte plus de
toute la journée
un équipement de travail devenues
indispensables
ce matin-là en ouvrant son établissement
franck découvre une surprise dont il se
serait bien passé plusieurs piles de
journaux lui ont été dérobés
ils m'ont piquée 1
ils m'ont piqué un bac dans le container
ce matin la pandémie il coronavirus ça
empêche pas les voleurs de d'agir mais
bon pourquoi continuer à venir
travailler dans ces conditions
franck nous explique les raisons je me
suis posé la question de savoir la
décision si j'allais travailler ou pas
ben moi je suis comme tout le monde j'ai
des encours financiers et puis je me
suis dit ton rôle que tu joues depuis 16
ans il faut continuer continuer à jouer
ce rôle
et puis donc je prends des précautions
je mets des grands je mets un masque et
puis on essaye de garder une certaine
distance tout en sachant qu'on peut
continuer quand même à vivre discuter
mais avec une sécurité pour le buraliste
garder son tabac ouvert contribue aussi
à maintenir un peu de lien social pas la
prétention de remplacer un psychologue
ou un psychiatre
c'est pas la question il ya un lien
social qu'elle a j'ai l'exemple par
exemple d'une dame qui a un certain âge
qui a autour de 50 52 ou 54 ans donc là
il ya un dialogue qui s'installe et puis
comme il ya quand même un isolement des
gens rient de la personne elle elle
parle un petit peu plus facilement des
gens prennent conscience de beaucoup de
choses et je pense que cette pandémie
7,7 ce qu'on finance ça ramène aussi
la réflexion ça ramène l'humain à la
réflexion et le sens le vrai sens de la
vie aussi
voilà d'origine italienne franck est
doublement touchés par cette crise
sanitaire
et comme tout le monde il espère que
l'élan collectif permettra d'en sortir
au plus vite